[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die dakar
härteste rallye der welt
seit 1978 findet das wüstenrennen start
30 jahre lang ist afrika der
austragungsort ziel ist dakar im senegal
gewesen
aber seit den terror drohen nimmt vom
2008 findet die dakar in südamerika
entstanden
die faszination
die strapazen für mensch und maschine
und die ledig langen wegstrecken sind
geblieben
jeden tag eine neue herausforderung
nicht berechenbar viel geld schweiß und
ausdauer werden in die vorbereitungen
gesteckt um einmal diese rallye zu
gewinnen ein sieg steigert das image des
sieger fahrzeugs ungemein es ist einfach
eines der letzten großen motorsport es
ist das größte rennen der welt
wahrscheinlich und das zu bestehen vom
start bis zum ziel wie gesagt
es ist das großartigste wintersport
event
seit 2003 nimmt das deutsche x-raid-team
mit seinen bmw an der dakar teil
zweimal wird das team um sven quandt
vierter zum sieg reichte es nicht ganz
[Musik]
zu stark ist damals die konkurrenz
volkswagen und mitsubishi heißen die
seriensieger in den vergangenen jahren
der große held war es der fahne
peterhansel
erinnerungen und emotionen hoch
wie ein spezieller code
geschwindigkeit
schwer vorzustellen dass ein fahrer
diese landschaft genießen kann wenn er
jeden moment gefahr läuft sich im sand
fest zu fahren und hoch konzentriert
sein muss
auf der straße fahren ist a relaxed das
hier ist der neue mini countryman seit
september 2010 auf den markt doch was
hat er mit der tat zu tun
der countryman ist basis einer
verrückten
er soll zum rallye fahrzeug umgebaut
werden und an der dakar 2011 und 2012
teil
die grundvoraussetzungen sind kommt
doch um wirklich offroad zu fahren
dürfte die bodenfreiheit der serien
version von knapp 15 cm zu gering seien
angetrieben wird der konsument von einem
1,6 liter benziner mit 184 ps das
maximale
im moment beträgt 240 minuten
aber dann turbolader kurzzeitig auf 2
geworden
die erwachsenen
[Musik]
rallyefahrer gorilla shisha ried sitzt
im serien countryman am steuer
in seinem rückspiegel ein wahres monster
das ist nämlich ein großer des tiroler
der neue dakar mit
im vergleich mit ihm unterlegt sein
countryman deutlich
der franzose soll der erste pilot des
deutschen x-raid-teams sein der den
wüsten mini nicht nur bewundern sondern
auch fahren darf
dezember 2010 das erste training nach
der entwicklung des fahrzeuges für
charlie dem gelände um ein
straßenfahrzeug für die dakar fit zu
machen ist fahrerische kompetenz und
technisches know how gefragt
die firma x-raid in der nähe von
frankfurt seit 2002 baut das unternehmen
auf rot bmw die dann an der dakar
teilnehmen
boss ist sven quandt mitglied der bmw
hauptaktionärs familie und selbst
mehrmaliger dakar teilnehmer
[Musik]
fünf jahre lang sind wir mit dem bmw x3
und dann ist diese serie ausgelaufen es
gibt es die neuen x3 aber der ist also
nicht ähnlich aber der ist von der optik
halt schon etwas ähnlicher daran nehmen
wir haben klar wir wollen ein ganz
anderes auto machen und haben dann mit
bmw gesprochen und wussten ja dass magna
auch den mini ab dann war sie den
countryman gebaut und man hat auch
vorher den x3 für bmw gebaut und dann
sagt es wird gesagt diese nehmen wenn
ich das auto und vermarktet die konzept
passe dass auch und sagen wir so ein
auto in die wüste stellen das ist hat
allen spaß gemacht sondern haben wir
gesagt ja kommen nehmen wir das
und das war auch gleich also ein relativ
großer erfolg wir haben das gesehen jede
in den mini sieht wirklich natürlich
toll februar 2011 mit dem mini geht es
aufwärts und zwar hoch in die alpen
[Musik]
drehort ist ihm ein berühmter skiort in
den französischen alpen nach einer idee
des teamfahrer scotia riet entsteht ein
actionfilm auch rolle der neue da kam
und was dieser geländewagen im schnee
auf 2000 meter höhe zaubert ist einfach
atemberaubend
[Musik]
ja es war haifas es waren
sicherheitsstand
es war eine verrückte idee eigentlich
und waren folgte die von dollar gewesen
vor einem jahr dass er jetzt hat er für
das gerne machen und dann hatten wir
lange diskutiert ja dann machen wir so
was wir wissen dass die autos natürlich
nicht viel schnee gemacht sind
eigentlich wenn man den film sieht
denken und der bewegt sich da eigentlich
normal jeden tag aber wir haben zwei
greifen gekriegt die man normalerweise
nicht mehr fährt
und wir haben passen verändern müssen
für das fahrzeug es war einfach mal was
ganz anderes zu zeigen was wir machen
cantieni war sehr happy darüber dass wir
das gemacht haben die haben uns
unterstützt sie haben uns auch
eingeladen dorthin kommen wir machen
alles sperren euch alle strecken dafür
hat und wir haben gesehen dass man mir
zu mini auf die skipiste hochfahren kann
und nicht nur runter rutschen das war
schon für uns alle erstaunlichen die
springen ist natürlich schon fantastisch
spätsommer 2010 erst vor wenigen wochen
ist die entscheidung gefallen einen mini
für die dakar zu bauen nachdem das
design von der österreichischen firma
magna schon fertig ist geht der nächste
auftrag an die firma hegemann heute cp
autosport den gitterrohrrahmen zu bauen
am anfang steht erst einmal die grafik
hier müssen die auflagen der fia des
internationalen automobil-verbandes
berücksichtigt werden genauso wie die
räumlichen bedingungen des mini sprich
der gitterrohrrahmen muss zum beispiel
an die lage des lenkrads der hinterachse
motors des getriebes des differenzials
und der vaart zelle angepasst werden
dann gehen die schweißarbeiten los
verwendet wird ein ganz spezieller
werkstoff eine legierung aus hochfestem
stahl der vor allem aus dem flugzeugbau
stammt
also der rahmen ist eine
eigenkonstruktion von uns sind haben wir
zum teil schon beim x3 benutzt der
unteren teil die obere ebene ist
komplett neu das sind hochfester stähle
die dabei benutzt werden und in
unterschiedlichen rohr stärken von 1,5
bis 2 mm 3 mm durchmesser sogar schwarz
stärke und durchmesser geht bis zu 50
millimeter hoch je nachdem auch was die
vier vorschreibt dafür dass man im
notfall mich so im auto auch sich
überschlagen kann ohne dass insassen was
passiert für mensch und maschine ist die
dakar nahe an der belastungsgrenze
seit 1978 gab es 60 tote die dakar ist
unberechenbar und umstritten sieg und
niederlage liegen dicht beieinander
an einem tag liegt ein spitzenfahrer
noch in führung doch am nächsten wirft
ein technischer defekt oder ein unfall
ein team aus der wertung wie zum
beispiel bei diesem heftigen unfall von
db und zitzewitz bei einer dakar
vorbereitungs rallye
wie durch ein wunder überleben die
piloten diesen horror crash und steigen
anschließend unverletzt aus dem völlig
zerstörten fahrzeug hier zeigt sich wie
wertvoll ein solcher gitterrohrrahmen
sein kann ohne ihn wären sie wohl nicht
mehr am leben
die idee ist verrückt innerhalb von drei
monaten soll ein neuer mini entwickelt
und gebaut werden
die firma cpp autosport soll einen
gitterrohrrahmen mit unterteilen in nur
vier wochen fertigstellen
[Musik]
detail wissen ist gefragt
das unterteil und das urteil wird
getrennt voneinander gefertigt um ein
späteres einfügen des mittel bodens zu
ermöglichen damit wir keine nahtstellen
hier haben um das eindringen von staub
und wasser zu vermeiden man versucht
immer ein relativ starkes fahrzeug zu
bauen was sich sehr wenig verbindet um
dadurch einen gleichmäßigen
fahrverhalten nicht die ganze zeit zu
haben
außerdem müssen die ingenieure
entscheiden inwieweit sie gewicht
einsparen dürfen hier leichter das
fahrzeug um so besser ist seine
wendigkeit aber umso unsicherer und
anfälliger ist der rahmen bei schweren
belastungen oder unfällen
also wählt man insgesamt einen
kompromiss aus sicherheit und leichtbau
tatsächlich ist es im vergleich zur
vorjahres konstruktion gelungen sieben
kilogramm einzusparen ohne auf
sicherheit zu verzichten
nun hat x-raid einem gitterrohrrahmen
der auf dem niveau der dakar
konkurrenten von volkswagen oder
mitsubishi ist
wobei diese beiden konkurrenten 2012
nicht am start sein werden
[Musik]
der bau dieses neuen rahmens ist also
zwingend erforderlich gewesen
technisch gesehen hat x-raid den mini
nun aufgerüstet und bietet ein starkes
und konkurrenzfähiges fahrzeug bei der
dakar
das ist natürlich ein sehr besonderer
moment gerade wenn es hier in diesem
fall um das erstfahrzeug geht hier zeigt
sich dann eigentlich ob im vorfeld
sauber gearbeitet worden ist ob wirklich
alle bausteine alle puzzleteile zusammen
passen und dann wenn die mannschaft
sieht okay die schweiz der letzten
wochen das hat sich gelohnt sich hier
reinzuhängen das ganze passt ineinander
und ein auto entsteht das ist natürlich
dann für alle beteiligten besonderer
moment und löst auch dann so ein
bisschen die fesseln des termindrucks
die man vorher hat
[Musik]
seit über einem jahr bearbeitet und
entwickelt das deutsche x-raid-team den
kleinen britischen flitzer nun ist
daraus ein top gelände rennwagen
geworden alleine die fahrzeugdaten
stimmen optimistisch 315 ps und ein
drehmoment von annähernd 700
newtonmetern sollen den mini sicher über
sanddünen und schotterpisten bringen
genug kraft für den 19 von den schweden
die höchstgeschwindigkeit liegt bei 180
stunden
bei rennings mit vielen schnellen
streckenabschnitten meter das 1 0 doch
bei der dakar gibt es sieben etappen wo
der untergrund mehr santos
dann kommt es nicht nur auf speed an
fahrwerksabstimmung mehr motor das
gewicht und nicht zuletzt die fahrer
sorgen für eine erfolgreich geschnürtes
paket
die maße des mini
34 länge und zwei metern
ist er sogar 13 cm länger als ein vw
golf 6
mini ist der mini also gar nicht
[Musik]
das x-raid-team sowie die spitzenfahrer
um stéphane peterhansel eben den
journalisten ein stelldichein
die geladene schreibende zunft erhält
gelegenheit den mini von außen und innen
kennen zu merken
termin
hier bot
vollgas geben
das ist hier schon etwas anderes
normalerweise kennst du als
fahrradreifen die strecke genau und
kannst fast bis an die grenzen
bei den rileys aber geben wir die
strecke jetzt da immer eine reserve
2009 stößt überraschend stéphane
peterhansel bmw mannschaft der
erfolgreichste dakar pilot aller zeiten
sechs mal hat er die rallye auf dem
motorrad und dreimal im auto gewonnen
wie jutta kleinschmidt fuhr er seine
ersten erfolge in einem mitsubishi
pajero einen 2004 2006 und 2007
insgesamt kommt er auf 9 dakar triumph
doch mitsubishi bricht sein dakar
engagement 2009 ab peterhansel sucht
sich ein neues team und geht zum
x-raid-team nach deutschland
[Musik]
die ganzen gehabt bei einer einheit die
etappe geworden den anderen bin ich mit
sieben ganz lediglich auf tuchfühlung
geblieben und habe
dann aber
was ist ein mann ohne die richtige frau
an seiner seite
andrea mayr aus süddeutschland die
offroad pilotin lernte stéphane 2003 im
team von mitsubishi kennen und wie heute
sind beide immer noch ein paar was ihnen
sicherlich von anderen unterscheidet er
es unheimlich analytischer er kann die
dinge sehr analytisch und sehr
emotionslos betrachten und auch
dementsprechend reagieren er hat eine
sehr gute balance egal was er macht ob
das jetzt am fahrrad ist oder am
skateboard war oder ob man ihn auf die
stelle der hat unheimliches balance
gefühl der franzose hat seit jahren
einen sehr guten beifahrer der ihm in
der wüste den rechten weg weisen
genauso nur dieses team zusammen
funktioniert gut wenn sie den bahnfahrer
austauschen werden sie merken dass das
schon nicht mehr so gut funktioniert
es ist eine strategie wie man fährt man
muss sich selbst zurück hat man kann
eine dakar nicht vollgas vom ersten tag
fahren das probieren die anfänger die
merken dass ein sehr schnell dass man
nach dem dritten vierten klassen ist
sich zurückhaltend und wissen welche
tage man schnell fahren was hat er beim
motorrad gezeigt und das zeigt er im
prinzip jetzt genauso wieder beim
fahrzeug
trotz aller triumphe stets der fahne mit
beiden beinen im leben ein typ zum
anfassen kein aalglatter medienstar
sondern bodenständig stets freundlich
und überraschender weise ohne allüren
[Musik]
stéphane peterhansel und andrea mayr
leben in chrom und tana in der schweiz
ausruhen vom wettkampfstress heißt für
sie cross country fahrer
andreas liebe gilt sowohl dem
motorradfahren als auch stéphane
also die stärken ganz klar das ist noch
mal der sport das bewegungstalent
was sich in dem besonders schätzt er hat
unheimlich viel humor ist wahnsinnig
tolerant und
zu den schwächen ich glaube es gibt nur
eine schwäche er kann nicht nein sagen
ortswechsel frankreich nördlich von
bangkok ist stéphane peterhansel geboren
hier leben seine kinder aus erster ehe
und sein vater
unten in der garage eine schier
unendliche trophäe
sie zeugt von triumph von seiner website
der motorrad und dakar
stolz zeigt er uns wie alles begonnen
hat
ihr motto mein vater hat mir das erste
motorrad geschenkt da war ich gerade mal
acht jahre alt es ist einfach die nummer
3 yamaha mit 80 zentimetern als ich dann
erwachsen war hat er dann einfach das
motorrad verkauft
vor zehn jahren habe ich dann
recherchiert um dieses motorrad dichter
zu filmen
ich hab's gefunden und dann sofort
zurück gekauft
hat es viel gekostet
es war ein ich habe einfach ein ganz
neues motorrad hingegeben und dafür mein
altes erhalten ich wollte unbedingt das
erinnerungsstück wieder
nach sechs motorrad- siegen bei der
dakar und zwei enduro weltmeister titeln
sucht er eine neue herausforderung und
wechsel 2002 auf vier räder ans steuer
eines mitsubishi pajero
motorrad nicht zu vergleichen im auto
ist das körperlich weniger anstrengend
als auf dem motorrad
fahren
natürlich die vielen sprünge
[Musik]
das braucht zeit
es dann gut im auto man muss eben viel
trainieren
zurück in portugal oktober 2011 stéphane
bereitet sich auf seine q3 über 50
journalisten wird er in den kommenden
zwei tagen chauffieren
sie hat eigene quelle er nutzt jede
fahrt als willkommene trainingseinheit
und so gibt ein champion folge
ein paar informationen aus den bergen
[Musik]
zurück zur entwicklung der bau des auto
körpers steht an dabei helfen
computergesteuerte fräsen den werkstoff
in diesem fall ton die richtige form zu
geben ton ist fest aber dennoch leicht
formbar und damit gut zu bearbeiten
[Musik]
in dieser halle befindet sich der vom
computer gesteuerte vrees arm dieser
trägt millimetergenau die schichten der
ton masse ab bis sich nach und nach die
einzelnen konturen der mini formen
erkennen lassen
anschließend erfolgt der feinschliff mit
hand und sandpapier
geschickte hände sind gerade beim
glätten und polieren immer noch besser
als der fräs arm des computers
[Musik]
und natürlich ist der chef gerade bei
diesem wichtigen prozess persönlich vor
ort um sich über den stand der
entwicklung zu informieren
40 verschiedene formen müssen produziert
werden das design kommt mittels
computergestützten vorlagen wieder aus
österreich von magna in graz
entwicklungsziel ist neben ständiger
reduktion des gewichtes auch eine
ansprechende optische gestaltung des
rennwagens
die produktion der außenhaut bildet den
teuren teil bei der entwicklung des mini
zumal kohlefaser stoffe verwendet werden
eine einzelne faser ist dünner als ein
menschliches haar
in längsrichtung sind die fasern extrem
steif und belastbar
seine festigkeit bekommt das material in
dem mehrere schichten von kohlefaser
matten übereinander in harz eingebettet
werden
hier werden oberflächen eingefärbt um
einen besseren visuellen gesamteindruck
zu gewinnen
[Musik]
nach dem einbringen aller verstärkung
und sandwich materialien wird die form
mit einer trend folie einem absaug vlies
und einer vakuum folie abgedeckt
zwischen der vakuum folie und der form
wird ein unterdruck erzeugt
luft wird abgesaugt
diesen prozess nennt man war komisch
danach werden die teile im ofen gebacken
und so gehärtet
[Musik]
anschließend erfolgt wieder feinarbeit
die mechaniker schreiten die noch
scharfen ränder der carbon teile ab
wobei sie die kanten nach glätten bevor
die eigentliche montage stattfindet
[Musik]
nun montieren wir den boden und
seitenwände und den raum oder benzin
tanken
das ist dann so weit fertig nachdem der
abgabe auf umsatz
und
dazu brauchten wir formen die gemacht
worden sind von denen wir dann die
kohlefaser form ab formen konnte die als
an die außenhaut darstellen
in den 60er und 70er jahren wurde noch
überwiegen stahl aluminium und holz an
rennautos verbaut bis der engländer john
barnard von mclaren bei
flugzeugherstellern auf das material
kohlefaser stieß und sogleich begeistert
war
1981 wurden die ersten kohlefaserteile
an einem formel 1 auto verbaut wenn es
heute darum geht ein bauteil mit
geringem eigengewicht und dennoch mit
einer sehr hohen dynamischen belastungen
herzustellen dann heißt die antwort
carbon
sven quandt selbst nimmt die montage ab
nichts will er dem zufall überlassen auf
seine partner ist aber verlass nach
abnahme der ersten vorlagen waren schon
vier wochen später die letzten anbau
teile der außenhülle fertig und
angebracht eine meisterleistung
zurück zum weingut adecco mayor in
portugal die journalisten sind dann den
mini zu begutachten und zu testen
[Musik]
die teststrecke verläuft um das weingut
ist fünf kilometer lang und drei meter
breit für die journalisten gibt es nun
genug möglichkeiten den mini in action
zu vor allem die ziel sprünge auf der
letzten geraden sind spektakulär
[Musik]
fürs auto ein guter test und für die
journalisten mit nervenkitzel pur
[Musik]
oder 20% geschwindigkeit habe ich
gegeben naja nicht ganz für den prozess
gibt man nicht alles aber wir fahren
doch sie nicht am limit die strecke
kennen aber keine maximale
so sehen es die piloten fahren nahe am
limit
[Musik]
was für die fahrer routine ist geht
nicht für den
die meisten journalisten sind nach ihren
kot weiß nach richtig aufgebaut
sehr schnell mehr als ich dachte
erstaunlich wie das auto works die
bremskräfte und dann wieder zu
beschleunigen
[Musik]
ich liebe
schon dass der pilot alles unter
kontrolle hatte ich habe da auch
irgendwie keine angst war es ein
erfahrener pilot war der abstand
ich dachte die ganze zeit und heute
noch immer
zu sehen
ich hatte auch angst das erste mal
unglaublich einfach urlaub ist
der letzte schritt wäre ich konnte mich
sicher und hatte keine angst
ich hatte mal einen 34
war
und der sprung sind beeindruckend
es war so eng da trenne ich kann kaum
rein aber wenn man dann drin sitzen
angeschnallt wird dann sitzt man viel
enger als im flugzeug da drin und es ist
eigentlich wie eine ganz sicheren käfig
und es war
die achterbahnfahrt ist wirklich nichts
dagegen das war der hammer das haben wir
ich bin ich schon ein paar autos
gefahren aber das war der hammer und
wann ist gefahren wie wie im rennen so
hatte ich den eindruck und manchmal habe
ich gedacht wir fliegen raus musste ich
sagen aber wir fliegen natürlich nicht
ganz aber ich bin mit besten fahrer der
welt unterwegs
dieses auto ist schon
bemerkt die tolle arbeit die das
x-raid-team da reingesteckt hat nach
meiner zeit mit dem extra
jeder hat versucht den schwerpunkt des
autos nach unten zu setzen wie bei einem
weltmeisterschafts autor
habe ein gutes gefühl bei meiner ersten
fahrt beginnen
attraktives publikum
sponsoren
journalisten tv teams und die besten
rallyefahrer der welt sorgen dafür dass
in campo major an zwei tagen mal so
richtig die luft brennt
viele stellt sich natürlich um den
favoriten ist der fahne pedale
[Musik]
wir müssen für seine gute kondition
haben
wenn ich eine gute vorbereitung zu haben
[Musik]
einzige
allerdings richtig
die sich komfortabler
kleinen springen ist es noch okay wird
bei wenigen leuten ist das manchmal
wirklich zu es gibt keinen
die teilnehmer am q drive und viele
schaulustige aus der weinregion umkämpft
werden diesen mini so schnell nicht
vergessen
[Musik]
x-raid im hessischen trebur bei
frankfurt die letzte phase der
entwicklung steht an alle komponenten
sind nun an einem ort jetzt kann man das
fahrzeug tatsächlich zusammenbauen
doch wenn eine dakar bevorsteht muss das
x-raid service team das den mini zur
dakar begleitet ständig am fahrzeug üben
das heißt alle acht x-raid fahrzeug
teams müssen das auto zerlegen und
wieder zusammensetzen können am besten
im schlaf
das geschieht bei der letzten phase der
entwicklung und später auch wenn weitere
x-raid modelle gebaut
[Musik]
2012 will das extra team mit drei bmw x3
und fünf mini an den start gehen dieses
auto erhält dann ein team von drei
mechaniker die jede schraube jedes
strebe die differenziale das getriebe
und so weiter jederzeit einsetzen können
[Musik]
insgesamt geht das x-raid-team mit 100
personen nach südamerika
schon daran kann man erkennen wie sehr
man diese dakar gewinnen möchte
die entwicklung ist fast abgeschlossen
es fehlt noch der motor und die
aussenhaut hat das neue dakar fahrzeug
noch irgendetwas mit dem mini countryman
zu tun oder ist das etwas ganz eigenes
naja wenn man doch einmal einen
schnellen blick wagt kann eigentlich
relativ schnell feststellen dass das
eigentlich mit einem serienauto relativ
wenig zu tun hat also von der technik
alles was unter der haut eigentlich ist
kann man überhaupt nicht mit dem
countryman aus der serie vergleichen
aber was wir natürlich schon wert darauf
legen ist und die aussenhaut für den
zuseher der dann im fernsehen dieses
auto zu fahren sid dass der sehr wohl
sie damit identifizieren kann und sieht
okay da ist eigentlich der countryman
mini countryman unterwegs den ich auch
auf der straße sehe aber unter uns
gesagt hat dass eigentlich von der
technik her relativ wenig damit zu tun
die letzten entwicklungstage dann wird
das fahrzeug zusammengesetzt
erstaunlich nur wenige handgriffe
genügen und die außenhaut ist am
fahrzeug angebracht
aber genau das ist ja die devise beim 90
alles muss schnell abgebaut und wieder
aufgebaut werden können damit man im
bedarfsfall schnell an defekte bereiche
herankommt und teile austauschen kann
als nächstes wird der motor vorbereitet
sollte jetzt etwas nicht passen könnte
man kaum noch reagieren doch alle
ingenieure und mechaniker sind
zuversichtlich das wichtigste ist eine
bevor man den motor ein gibt dass
sämtliche kabel schläuche alle gut
verlegt sind wenn auch wenn das wenn die
dramen und
positionen servern kommt man immer so
gut dazu also die schläuche die kabel
alles noch mal checken ob das okay ist
das richtig eingegipst ist erwünscht ist
umso mühsamer dann noch einmal
heranzukommen und also das macht das
macht sinn wo man das vorher mal endlich
ist der motor dran weil er so schwer ist
wird er mit einem gabelstapler an die
entsprechende stelle gehievt damit die
mechaniker für die montage alle hände
frei haben
mit diesem antrieb wird der x-raid mini
zum ersten offiziellen mini mit einem
längs eingebauten motor und
sechszylinder dazu kommen noch zwei
turbolader wie dem dreiliter bmw-motor
auf 315 ps an kunden
[Musik]
ich muss sagen es ist ein mal was neues
ein neues projekt und die ich bin mir
sicher der der countryman szene sehr gut
und wird sie sicher super bewegen in der
wüste
drei monate lang tag und nacht waren
entwickler ingenieure und mechaniker
dabei das fast unmögliche möglich zu
machen in so kurzer zeit ein neues
rallye auto zu bauen letztendlich hat es
funktioniert
großes vertrauen in alle partner muss
man dazu sagen sonst fährt für sonst
hätte man so ein projekt auch glaube ich
nicht angefangen also magna in dem falle
in graz bmw auch die leute in steyr und
aber auch ganz besonders faster in
frankreich haben maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen
geholfen hat natürlich eine ganze menge
dass wir
schon sehr sehr viel zusammen gemacht
haben in den letzten jahren alle
parteien sich sehr gut kannten und man
wusste wie man relativ schnell handeln
kann und die neuen medien oder die
kommunikation per e mail in dem falle
bis zum exzess geübt worden ist das zum
teil wirklich 24 stunden um antworten
ganz schnell hinzubekommen
das war schon eine meisterleistung und
dann haben wir in den letzten 14 tagen
drei wochen ist ein mini design auch
noch dabei gewesen die ihren teil dazu
beigetragen haben was sie gerne so oder
anders hätten und auch das hat sehr gut
funktioniert also wenn alles nicht so
reibungslos gelaufen wäre würden wir
heute nicht hier sitzen und sagen auto
läuft und ist eigentlich so weit ganz
weiß ich sehr gut geworden
unglaublich wie viele einzelne schritte
wie viele prozesse
phrasen die entwicklung eines autos
kraft
und außerdem kostet das alles
[Musik]
also eine ganze praktisch ein neues
modell entwickeln wie wir es jetzt
gemacht haben von dem bmw x3 auf den
mini countryman das kostet schon relativ
viel da kann man sagen das ist im
bereich zwischen erhalten millionen und
600.000 euro etwa so liegt das denn die
man braucht um ein komplett neues also
endlich ein komplett neues fahrzeug um
ein fazit was man hat weiterzuentwickeln
und eine neue außenhaut darauf zum euro
bei den größten teil davon bestimmt die
außenhaut denn die die positive
negativform sind relativ aufwändig der
mini sich auf der dakar bewährt tatsache
ist dass jedes jahr die hälfte aller
fahrzeuge das ziel nicht erreicht
verursacht durch unfälle oder technische
defekte
ausfall gründe gibt es an einem
prototypen ungefähr 1,5 millionen denn
vom pfennig teil bis zum großen teil
kann alles kaputt gehen das ist technik
dass es motorsport man kann selbst
ausfallen und krank werden aber ich sag
mal die autos sind
hightech aber robust gebaut und da die
richtige mischung zu finden dass man
auch fehler eines fahrers das auto
kompensiert irgendwo gegen dicken stein
fährt oder so darf nicht drin alles
abbrechen logischerweise das ist die
kunst an der geschichte das
erfolgreichste fahrzeug der dakar war in
der vergangenheit der mitsubishi pajero
mit 27 25 jahren das ist kaum zu toppen
der vorteil des pajero leichte montage
und
nach unfällen oder technischen defekt
die servicefreundlichkeit ist weil er
darin eine wichtigsten punkte dass man
mit sehr wenigen handgriffen relativ
viel sozusagen an dem auto machen kann
auch einfach machen kann einfach
nachsehen kann wenn man jetzt einen
normalen stahl
body hätte oder ein kompletter
kundschaft koch sowie jetzt gehabt haben
früher beim x3 hat den nachteil dass man
dann durch die löcher die vorhanden sind
greifen muss oder die klappe aufmachen
muss und dann diese herankommen konnte
jetzt kann man wirklich das auto einmal
die außenhaut abnehmen und kann überall
sehr sehr leicht dran man gibt die
servicefreundlichkeit ist dadurch höher
aber auch dies geht wie sie nicht
schneller insgesamt so ein fahrzeug zu
montieren heute demontieren radwechsel
ein nützliches gimmick ist der
ausfahrbare stempel der das auto auf
jedem untergrund hoch drückt damit
verlieren die piloten viel weniger zeit
als früher um ein rad zu wechseln
diese prozedur wird über ein dutzend mal
trainiert damit jeder handgriff schnell
selbst die zeit für den wechsel eines
rad beträgt eine minute und 30 sekunden
letzter test vor dem ernstfall aufgabe
gemeistert
das rad ist montiert
reinsetzen für zu stempel einfahren
los gehts shakedown das heißt nach den
letzten nachbesserungen der vater ist
eine kiesgrube bei wiesbaden noch mal
werden alle systeme überprüft und der
wagen für ein paar stunden voll
beansprucht
doch einfahrten allein kann die dakar
nicht überstehen wer braucht der
zuschauer es leute die die fahrzeuge
nach jeder etappe reparieren in der
grundausstattung ist es bei jedem
unserer lkw so dass wir alle ersatzteile
haben die wir brauchen um service zu
machen oder reparaturen wenn irgendetwas
ausfällt oder kaputt geht dass man
einfach alles tauschen kann wir haben
groß an den seiten einzelnen gepackt
offen wo dann einzeln verpackt in ein
bisschen kohle die ersatzteile drin sind
also
wir haben hier außen einmal
getriebe
differenziale lenkungs systeme wir haben
hier weil meine lkw natürlich auch für
für den fond und getriebe ist noch mal
zusätzlich fächer um eben die
wartungsarbeiten in den dämpfern zu
machen und hier hinten ziemlich gleich
bei fast allen in lkws boxen mit den
kleinen ersatzteilen
dann verteilt hier im lkw haben wir
jetzt auch die größeren ersatzteile die
einen wollen die kleinen kisten nicht
reinpassen wie zum beispiel schläuche
von den turbos die aluminiumrohre aber
auch equipment wie zum beispiel hier
oben die lampen um im zelt nach zelt zu
machen ist eine sache die mich immer
sehr beeindruckt an den autos wenn man
das mit einem normalen fahrzeug jetzt
vergleicht ist die anzahl einfach an
kühler paketen die in so einem fahrzeug
sind hier wird gekühlt aktiv sie bremsen
das fordert die findigsten mittelschiff
der motor öl wasser steering diese jedes
hat ein einzelnes kühlsystem und
natürlich die dämpfer auch die können
wenn sie zu heiß werden wenn das
gegenüber kocht platzen die einfach und
da gibt es auch sieht man vielleicht
nachher am auto noch in ein aktives
kühlsystem wo sie vorne angeströmt
werden und hinten noch mal richtig
angeblasen werden
da in allen rennen die spitze so nah
beieinander liegt ist eine der
kritischen faktoren sind die reifen ein
ausfall bedeutet zeitverlust
die man in der regel stadt deswegen
tauschen wir zu jeder möglichkeit die
wir haben die reifen komplett aus diesem
grund gibt es auf jedem lkw einen großen
vorrat an reifen normalerweise braucht
man keine ist aber auch schon
vorgekommen dass wir jetzt letztes jahr
auf der dakar vier reifen platten hat
ein fahrzeug hat leider maximal nur drei
ersatzreifen dabei was dann bedeutet das
dass so etwas natürlich sehr kritisch
ist für das ergebnis letztes jahr was so
dass er stefan peters sind alle 15
kilometer anhalten musste um die reifen
wieder aufzufüllen
weil alle platt war weil 1 blatt war das
nicht getauscht werden konnte
bei der kommenden taka werden über zwölf
service trucks eingesetzt
nur noch wenige wochen bis zur rallye es
wird ernst
zum ersten mal wird diesel in den
riesentank des mini eingefüllt
fassungsvermögen 420 liter damit kommt
man etwa 1000 km
co pilot michelle prüft die systeme im
innenraum während der car thief die
letzten teile der außenhaut an den
nagelneuen mini anbringt
[Musik]
wir haben hier das erste mal ein neues
system benutzt wir haben die außenhaut
komplett modular gemacht dass man
relativ schnell auch das design oder die
farben ändern kann am fahrzeug aber auch
sehr servicefreundlich man kann die
komplette außenhaut abnehmen innerhalb
von zehn minuten für eine stunde etwa
und hat so auch in derselben zeit wieder
dran der franzose guerlain chicherit
darf als erster pilot den mini auf einer
dakar fahren der franzose ist schon seit
sieben jahren in diensten von axway
der ehemalige extremskifahrer liebt das
risiko den speed und besondere aufgaben
nun ist es soweit die erste ausfahrt
nach fertigstellung des autors
beiträge auf einem einfachen feldweg
kommt der wagen zu seiner jungfernfahrt
läuft er überhaupt und funktioniert
alles das sind die wichtigsten fragen
wie das x-raid-team in dieser phase
beschäftigt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
goran hadzic ried und sein französischer
copilot wie schon parat mit den ersten
einschätzungen
[Musik]
der neue mini fühlt sich erst mal gut an
es ist ein sehr schönes auto das wird
gute bilder geben auf der nacken
ich freue mich schon jetzt auf die erste
etappe bei der dakar
zuerst muss man mal sagen dass die idee
klasse
gleichzeitig schön
gut konstruiert mit eigentlich bekannten
elementen vom extra
wir haben den bmw zuletzt gefahren und
die technik steckt nun in
den vergangenen wochen haben alle
großartige
wir wissen allerdings nicht ob mit dem
mini ein gutes ergebnisse aus und das
fahrzeug zuverlässig
so in frankreich
der letzte und wichtigste test vor der
dakar er wird aufschluss darüber geben
wie gut eigentlich der mini ist
der so genannte car cicek nochmal alle
systeme im inneren
das service zell steht in der nähe von
lyon auf einem extremen gelände parcours
die letzten vorbereitungen werden
getroffen
[Musik]
der wagen soll hier einen richtigen
belastungstest unterzogen werden
corinna chicherit ist selbst gespannt
was ihn in den nächsten minuten erwartet
der franzose ist vierfacher weltmeister
in der extrem schief riva klasse der
umstieg von ski ins cockpit von schnee
auf sandfeld dem französischen rallye
meister von 2002 leicht
denn man muss das gefühl zu den
untergrund auch als pilot im auto
entwickeln
wem das gefühl fehlt
er wird stecken bleiben
jetzt gibt sie richtig gas
impressionen vom belastungstest
[Musik]
mein erster eindruck ist überwältigt
prima und so auflegen dieses neue auto
zu finden
die letzten design bilder vorher aber
das hier heute war richtiges einfahren
der wagen ist richtig gut es macht
riesenspaß mit einem großen
wir haben uns angestrengt ich glaube es
ist ein ganz guter wurf gelungen und
natürlich ist es von der optik ein auto
was alle so verlieben sage ich mal sagen
das ist richtig richtig sie es auch
ihnen richtig groß geworden ist klar
aber countryman ist sowieso ein bisschen
größer
ist ein schönes auto geworden
das ist also der dakar mini all4 racing
doch bei der dakar hat er leider nicht
so gut abgeschnitten wie alle gehofft
hatten bei halbzeit des rennens läuft
der mini noch auf platz neun
chicherit bei einem unfall richtig
zerlegt hatte
der wagen konnte leider nicht mehr
repariert werden für die nächste dakar
aber ist das fahrzeug gut gerüstet
[Musik]
der motor des mini ist übrigens der
gleiche den wir vorher schon im bmw x3
hatten
ich bin mir sicher dass es der beste
motor für diese auto klasse 3 liter
hubraum diesel und ein doppelter turbo
damit haben wir viel leistung aber das
beste ist nicht die leistung
viel drehmoment für alle bedingungen um
zb im sand bist dann ist das nötig noch
mehr drehmoment mitzubringen mit diesem
auto ist es wirklich einfach die löhne
zu überqueren für mich ist das hier der
beste motor
nach dem enttäuschenden abschneiden bei
der letzten dakar ist favorit stéphane
peterhansel dennoch recht optimistisch
was die prognosen für die kommende dakar
angeht
es würde eine etwas seltsame tag an den
volkswagen wird dann nicht mehr dabei
sein
[Gelächter]
dann würde es mein zehnter sieg sein ich
bin also wirklich motiviert
[Musik]
während des gesamten jahres haben wir
viel am auto gearbeitet um es zu
verbessern
es war kein leichter job in diesem jahr
trotz der vielen arbeiten und
verbesserungen am fahrzeug ist der mini
ein erfolgreiches ein jahr gefahren
zwei zweite plätze und ein sieg konnte
peterhansel mit höchsten schweizer bei
vorbereitungs release erreichen
ich denke dieses auto kann nun die dakar
gewinnen weil die fahrleistungen auf
einem sehr hohen niveau
aber man kann es nie wissen
die dakar ist ein sehr langes nicht
leichtes und sehr kompliziertes
aber wir haben ein echt gutes niveau es
ist möglich die dakar mit diesen mini
countryman zu gewinnen
ein ganz spezieller und wichtiger test
ist marokko hier sind die bedingungen
ähnlich wie auf der dakar in chile und
niveau
[Musik]
eine menge sand eine menge schotter für
die fahrer ideales trainingsgelände
[Musik]
der ganze stolz des x-raid-teams
der mini countryman
[Musik]
bonn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das x-raid-team ist bereit den tag
ankommen
[Musik]